hey everyone and welcome to string Queen
your weekly fan discussion about the
best TV shows and movies you should
stream right now I'm the Anna Galera and
I'm ash Crossin Leigh Ann covers a ton
of TV I cover a ton of movies and now
we're in this kind of weird time where
everyone is digesting all of these TV
and movies from the comfort of their
couch and we just want to bring you guys
a little of that joy and share what we
recommend definitely kovat 19 has shaken
up our daily lives I think that's fair
to say most of us have been in
self-isolation for many weeks now and so
we just wanted to create the show to
connect a little bit more share what you
guys are enjoying share what we're
binging you've got a lot of
recommendations and just kind of have
fun in this strange time right like if
you're looking for the next thing to
watch after titer King if you binge so
much Parks and Rec in the office over
and over again and you need something
else we got you covered
Oh totally we're also doing something
really fun where we're doing a rewind of
the week
well we dig into our vaults and we watch
something that you haven't seen in years
and we're gonna spill some exclusive EG
secrets along the way so you don't want
to miss that and of course there is a
ton of news coming through that we have
weeded through for you and we will give
to you right now and I think that's
where we should start what do you think
oh oh definitely ash let's start off
with a small screen that's a big screen
the small screen although so on one big
reading right now it's grated it fingers
crossed you sprung for the big screen
sometimes I will just stand here and
watch television for hours I love it
over on the TV side of things coded 19
essentially halted production for
everyone and everyone was kind of left
off in different stages of their TV
schedule and this mainly has affected a
lot of our typical broadcast shows
Network shows that have the seasons from
fall to spring and right now we would
typically be seeing a lot of those
season finales that's not really the
case why don't you make up your own
ending oh sure well a wonderful idea
shows
kind of in scramble mode right now
trying to figure out what they're gonna
do for their season finales because it's
not looking like we're gonna be going
back into production anytime soon so for
example if Grey's Anatomy decided you
know what we're just gonna make the last
episode that we shot our season finale
and luckily for them it was bonkers as
always so that worked out for Grey's and
also we're actually hearing rumors that
their original season finale was
supposed to kill off one of the main
characters in an explosion or a plane
crash or whatever happens in that day
hospital died a natural death I don't
think so
luckily someone has kind of got a little
bit of time before they might have to
meet the TV Grim Reaper but so while
Grey's decided just to call it we have
other shows like supernatural that was
supposed to wrap it's 15th and final
season that's just kind of left on pause
at the moment it has two episodes to go
and they have promised the fans that
they will eventually get this serious
finale if we go down then we go down
swinging awesome good news because
everything's a little kind of weird
right now I gotta give a shout out
because HBO's doing something really
cool as of April they have released over
500 hours of TV and movies for free what
that's right you don't have to have a
subscription so you can finally watch
the wire because we know we always have
that one friend who's like I watched the
wire when it was on and it was so great
well now you can watch The Wire - you
can watch True Blood Silicon Valley
Barry which I highly recommend so dive
into HBO subscriptions now you have no
excuse not to ash I know that you've
already been tapping into that free
stuff that we're gonna be chatting a
little bit later about I have I am
almost done with a certain show that we
will be talking about a little bit I'm
excited okay I should fill me in on
what's going on with movies because I
know that like TV everything has changed
everything has changed and it's co resi
but I'm gonna start I'm gonna start high
and break this down for some reason some
good news if you guys have followed me
at all you know that I love to
franchises more than any
star wars and the MMC you I'm not
talking with the marvel cinematic music
I'm talking about the Mamma Mia
cinematic universe
[Music]
and Lily James the star of Mamma Mia -
here we go again video chatted with all
her cast mates and she had the audacity
to read this caption Mamma Mia 3 it's
happening do I think she's joking
probably am I going to take this as
hopefulness possible news absolutely
oh yeah movies by the way Tom Hanks and
Rita Wilson executive produced them
because Rita loves briefs and wanted to
make them all Mamiya movies that is the
best fun fact that I've heard in a very
long time every time like I see an
interview with Tom Hanks when I asked
him about the next Mamma Mia
somebody's gotta get the scoop is it
happening I hold out hope that that
movie will happen but speaking of my the
dune hype is building I love your photos
out from that movie which is like a big
pop-culture novel slash movie of our
time that I assume like a lot of people
have never seen oh yeah I'm so I'm so
hyped for this movie I think it's gonna
be fantastic yeah I guess I would just
describe it as like science fiction
mania bonkers mesh stuff um but it has
every cast member ever in a Timothy
shallow mix Oscar Isaacs e'tenday'eh
Jason Momoa our good friend David des
mulchand is in it as well and I'm
reading the novel now and I will report
back but I will say that Timothy
sha'lame is giving me some emo boy kylo
Ren vibes kind of like it and then just
to bring us down note the so we're
talking about all these like productions
that have been delayed and one I just
want to acknowledge up front is because
they sleep because they are the studio
that's like we are going to plan out our
schedule for the rest of our lives
in heaven which they have and now with
everything going on everything is
shifting back and we're like slowly
seeing this because Disney has a movie
almost every single weekend of the year
now that they've acquired Fox so now
they're having to race late their entire
schedule to not conflict with their own
movies yes so it's kind of this weird
puzzle dance but just to give you a
little bit of this marble slate plots
coming up Black Widow has been pushed
from May we're supposed to get that next
month to November 2020 of course we did
the Eternals is down in February 2021
shanky May 20 21 Doctor Strange November
20 21
Thor love and thunder is now February 20
22 oh I am so pumped for that movie 20
22 is just breaking my heart out of this
list I am most pumped for that one end
it is thus far the farthest and then a
little bit of bright news like up bring
it back up for you guys
Captain Marvel to officially announce
for July 2022 that was previously like
untitled Marvel movie on the schedule
but now it's Captain Marvel - yeah and
then let's bring us back down can't
unite for too long
New Mutants never coming out I don't
think I think but New Mutants isn't it
okay - break this down for the fans out
there because New Mutants you guys it
has the biggest roller coaster ride and
Ash's been following it from the very
beginning so enlighten everyone okay
guys this is a ride I hope you're ready
strap in
check your seat belts here we go New
Mutants wrapped filming in September
2017 we were but babies yet didn't know
what was to come in our lives it was
supposed to come out April 30th 2018
that was the original release date and
then in that January they pushed it to
February of the next year to make room
for Deadpool you killed it
then it got pushed again to August 2019
to make room for Dark Phoenix movies
and then the trailer drop and it was
like super horror if ik and everyone
loved it they were like oh is scary more
like a Marvel movie that's scary I love
it so then they planned extensive
reshoots for this movie because they
were like we need to make it scarier
apparently those reshoots never happen
and then March 2019 happens which is
when Disney acquires Fox yes messes that
everything up again because like I said
before it's just he has all of these
weekend's and they were like where are
we gonna put New Mutants now we can't
have it like conflicting with our own
movies so then in May 2019 they pushed
it to April 3rd 2020 obviously that did
not happen it was so close we were so
close and then come on a virus happens
and they pulled it from the schedule I
don't believe it ever shot I don't
believe it exists I do not buy it
obviously like a lot of faith is not
being put into this movie for whatever
reason so at this point I just feel like
if they put it on Disney Plus it would
probably do good we would all watch it
oh yeah I don't I just don't know how
lucrative Beca be but we would all watch
it but why don't we talk about things
that we can't stream because we can
stream New Mutants and we'll never be up
with streaming cuz it's never coming out
but dream onward the Pixar movie it's
available in Disney Plus early very
early and obviously it's like you know
if you like to cry like all Pixar's
movies make you that will happen for you
and if you miss outside you can live
vicariously through them on their
journey yeah if you want to live in a
tree and like I secretly do you that
again um anyway onwards cute watch it
Pixar Tom Hall and Chris Pratt we love
them underwater starring Kristen Stewart
nobody watched it and it is a great
movie it is freaky it's kind of like an
alien but underwater
Kristen Stewart in her underwear
fighting Thanks
Kristen Stewart he's my crush and that's
available on digital now you can rent it
buy it
I think buy it but it's a great movie
and everyone should watch it and then
another one I want to shout out is on
over on Netflix Oh movie called uncorked
because this is the one that I think it
got kind of buried a little bit in the
algorithm but it's a cute movie about a
guy who his dad wants him to follow in
his footsteps but he just wants to be
like a Somali and drink wine and so if
you like wine and barbecue and rom-com
and family it's a really cute movie and
by the way the guy in it mama duo che
was also in underwater
I like the cross over there I like my
mom and also yes and I'm also liking the
fact that it's about wine because we've
been consuming quite a bit of that
lately
[Music]
yeah if you're like me at you have
consumed so much wine that you want to
feel like I don't know like a little
smarter about it like fantastic and then
I just want to give a shout out
personally on Hulu because this is where
I watch SNL SNL did their at-home
episode yes I'm so glad you brought this
up it was so fantastic I like it kind of
reminded me of like the days back before
these people were casted and they were
doing all their YouTube videos and like
I used to watch like Beck Bennett and
Kyle Mooney and Chloe Fineman all the
time and it kind of just like gave me
that it just gave everybody that but
hadn't watched that and also they did
like a zoom sketch that was hilarious
so perfect so OnPoint and I love the
fact that they got Tom Hanks to be their
virtual host of the of the week he did
great not really scared cuz he was like
I'm bald it's for a role I was like oh
my god everyone protected Tom Hanks I
loved the SNL came back into our lives
so definitely something to look forward
to every week continuing on what to
stream over on TV now available on
Netflix is a brand new show that's right
from the streaming site that brought you
the circle and love is blind get ready
for too hot to handle a show that puts
ridiculously attractive people at close
quarters but they're not allowed to
touch each other or themselves
I love toxic thing that Netflix is doing
to us I love it so basically they start
off with a grand prize ten thousand each
but if they break the rules the prize
money goes down lower and lower and
lower
it sounds outrageous I cannot wait to
watch it so definitely get excited for
that one ash next up something that I
love right now is on Hulu little fires
everywhere it is Reese Witherspoon and
Kerry Washington really bringing the
heat to this series it is so good the
season finale is actually gonna be
coming out on Wednesday April 22nd you
guys can binge the entire thing right
now
based off of the best-selling book and
this has been my favorite book to screen
adaptation that I've seen in a very long
time
cannot recommend it more go check that
one out also something else that I'm
super pumped about is that killing Eve
is back into our lives season 3 is
finally here but you know what you guys
can go back every watch the first two
seasons because they're only eight
episodes each and you can watch that on
an SI BBC America or Hulu so you have no
excuse a lot of fun kicked butt
female-centric shows right now that I'm
just so excited about ash let's be
honest there's a lot of stream these
days a lot and I feel like everyone is
constantly been like have you watched
this oh my gosh have you checked out
that yes we have because we all have so
much time right now so Ashton I have a
fun segment for you guys it's called if
you like that watch this oh yeah it's a
new dance move everyone has been talking
about tiger King everyone knows what
this show is you know what it's over we
watched our reunion show and now it's
time to broaden our horizons because I
have another recommendation for you guys
so if you liked Tiger King I'm saying
watch McMillion do you guys remember the
McDonald's Monopoly game of the 90s of
our childhood we all wanted to win that
game did you know that the entire time
the game was going on it was rigged I'm
not gonna spoil it for you guys but this
is a behind the scenes look at the FBI
team who cracked the case and realized
that McDonald's was unaware that their
Monopoly game was hijacked and was being
distributed piece by piece in those
little candy containers from the machine
yeah machine and passed out to friends
and family members
it is absolutely wild it doesn't have as
many crazy characters as tiger king but
the concept is even better what are your
thoughts on a - yeah so you told me
about the show we last week I started it
last night because I was like I'll check
it out and then I watched five episodes
so I'm almost done
um it's bonkers it's bonkers it'd get
definitely like I think the difference
between Tiger king and this one is Tiger
king like keeps unfolding in a way where
you don't know upfront what the whole
thing is a bow from yeah millions up
front is like hey this whole thing is a
scam and we're gonna tell you all the
layers in it and also instead of having
all of this footage it's more like
retelling and interviews but the people
they interview are so fascinating it's
crazy
also shout out to the dramatic
reenactment actors superb in this I
secretly want to be the traumatic
reenactment actor I'm sure it's a lot
harder than it looks but it just looks
like so much fun
it really does it really does yes so you
guys if you liked Tiger King watch
millions so that is my watch this that
recommendation ash I know you got one
for us right now I'm so much got one
because I've been rebuilding the show
and I think it fell under the radar for
a lot of people if you like the office
if you like Parks and Rec you need to
watch community the whole thing is
available on Netflix right now for the
first time it was an NBC show mm-hmm hi
Dan Harmon who does Rick and Morty and
the Russo brothers sued at Arrested
Development but then they went on to do
like a couple of like what are those
called Avengers movies no big deal
so you're combining like all of these
geniuses together amazing direction and
it's basically just a show about a bunch
of people in a community college it's
got a great ensemble cast Joel McHale
leads it Donald Glover pre childish
gambino Alison Brie just an exceptional
cast with a lot of cameos a lot of
awesome stuff but it's really like a
satire on just like all sitcoms
so a few different episodes okay like oh
my god we're doing a bottle episode or
they'll do like a horror themed episode
or they'll do a Star Wars paintball
themed episode which is the season
finale of season two so it's kind of
like a situational comedy but a very
self-aware one yeah
like kind of like how scream is a hot
like a slasher movie but they're also
making fun of it it's like community as
a sitcom but it's making fun of other
sitcoms I love that
that it's brilliant leave this next into
what are you binging and ash I think you
just told us I have absolutely binging
community because I haven't watched it
since like 2012 or whenever that was i
watch it like when i first moved out to
LA with my roommates and I loved it and
now the Netflix and I could just put it
on day after day after day I am burning
through this show there's a saying
throughout the show six seasons enemy
weeks six seasons and a movie that is
like the part of a successful show has
six seasons on a movie and we have the
six seasons we do not have the movie
need the movie the movie ever happen so
a comic-con last year I asked the
brothers if we were gonna get the
community movie because they keep like
weirdly teasing it so mm-hmm I think
were gonna roll the tape roll the tape
roll the clip I mean never seen never
you know we would love to see it happen
as much as anyone
you know Julio is the movie at this
point so you know if we want to complete
the six seasons in a movie Elantra so
who knows seems like they really do want
to do it I feel like everyone is down
the fans the cast and feel like people
want this to happen
yeah and this just in me talked to Joel
McHale like just now about we have a new
update and even newer one well I hope it
happens I know that I know that Alison
Brie tweeted that she got a call from
Sony and I think there's there's a world
where it happens but as you know a lot
has to happen before scripts have to be
written actors have to be available I
mean all these steps have to I would do
it in New York minute I honestly think
that the fans want it it's all it's very
on par right now reunions are all the
rage so I feel like and the fact that
it's just gone on to Netflix I wouldn't
be surprised with Netflix made this all
happen yeah
they would be very smart to do that yes
very smart make it happen
make it out what are you doing what do
you been drinking okay well I started
off engine lost for the very first time
and I was trying to get into it but it
just made me realize that I would love
to be on a deserted island right now or
just anywhere outside of my apartment
says you know I'm going to put this on
pause let's watch something that feels a
bit more attainable right now I want to
be back inside of an office so I decided
to start watching the good fight because
I loved The Good Wife with julianna
margulies
i binge through all seven seasons of
that show in one setting and the good
fight has been out for a couple seasons
season four just premiered on April 9th
on CBS all access but I was kind of
subconsciously waiting so I like stock
pile a bunch of seasons so that I could
have so much to binge I like to do that
Ash I've got something that's going to
make you so excited right now the good
fight stars Christine Baranski it is
Mamma Mia related
by the way hurry mama mia here we go
again
so classic classic but no I love
Christine Baranski and seeing her
reprise her role as Diane Lockhart like
honestly like if she were to run for
president I said yes let me vote for you
right now
she is fantastic the show is so smart
and and honestly I feel like lately I've
been binging a lot of just easy bin
jabal it's delicious TV but it's just
been not very highbrow and watching this
show it's fun I feel like I'm learning I
feel like I get to pick up on the
legalese so the good fight is what I'm
doing right now I'm having a lot of fun
but one of my secret favorite things to
do during this quarantine is to dive
into my ridiculous vault of DVDs that
I'm really glad I didn't throw away or
give away because yeah I've been
revisiting things I haven't watched in
10 years which kind of brings us to the
segment rewind rewind of the week that's
right ash and I are taking a look back
at some of our favorite movies and TV
shows that we haven't watched in a while
and this week it's all about the classic
90s movie can't hardly wait oh when when
it was socially acceptable to have a
wild party and not be more than six feet
apart from each other remember the days
ash well you know what Jennifer Love
Hewitt definitely remembers those days
because each II caught up with her in
2018 and asked her what she remembers
film in the movie and where she thinks
Amanda Beckett yes her character looks
slow motion into parties where she would
be today and I was not anticipating her
answer take a look I filmed that at the
same time that I was doing party of five
so I would work all day at party five
and then I would go and I would film can
hardly wait so I remember being very
tired but I remember also thinking like
wow this is like our generations or our
90s version of like pretty and pink and
sixteen Candles and all of those like
iconic movies that you just love and it
was really it was really fun and I got
to be with Seth again who I had known
from doing stuff and Brecon and I mean
everybody which is great where do you
think she ended up today
I think she's one of the one of the
housewives it's my goal for her I think
that it's a goal that's a real goal she
wants me a housewife a real housewife
which that tracks the tracks yeah where
a housewife yuri watched this movie what
was your initial reaction because we
have so many fun Easter eggs and fun
fact that we need to go over I look back
at that movie thinking like oh it's like
this team rom-com of the 90s and I don't
I didn't remember how funny it was yeah
it was so funny it's a pure comedy Allah
josie and the pussycats same directors
and a lot of the same actors - yeah
let's have our 3/4 of du jour and it our
boys Donald Faison Seth Green and
Breckin Meyer all in it and it's got a
kick-ass soundtrack as well yes yes a
jerkin soundtrack a jerkin soundtrack
cool in your word for cool be jerkin as
in dude that's jerkin in history but I
love you pointed out that we've got so
many famous faces in there um I could
not believe how many stars that I saw at
such a young age in this movie Lincoln
to miss it
selma Blair as girl Mike hits on number
two Jason Segel as watermelon guy which
I was not expecting to see but I know
that you knew that he was already in the
movie yeah so a couple years ago Jason
Segel face had a big crush on me as my
iPhone background and everything so when
I saw so many fun famous faces I also
love seeing Clea Duvall in there and
Sara Rue in my favorite role of the
entire movie shout out to her you know I
dug into some little fun facts about
can't hardly wait and I can't wait to
share them with you because you have
nowhere else to go right now so you're
gonna listen hit me
one of my favorite fun facts about this
movie is the fact that Peter Facinelli
he's playing much Dexter the ultimate
cool guy when Peter was filming this
movie he had just had a little baby
infant and one day he showed up to set
and had a big scratch on his eye from
the baby and they're filming a scene
where he's
talking to his friends about breaking up
with their girlfriends and they're
saying they can't do it and the entire
time in the scene he's just in the
shadows and you cannot any other half of
his face because they couldn't not film
that being that day they're on such a
tight production schedule there's baby a
cat how this happen I need more info
like how fragile like actors have to be
during this time cuz they're like they
can't do anything don't touch me
they can't go snowboarding anything
another little fun fact for you is that
the iconic song where he's going up and
you singing Paradise City
[Applause]
[Music]
I love that scene so much it almost
didn't happen they originally wanted to
use a van Halen song Panama but they
couldn't afford the rights to it I know
that song is like bacon pop culture but
I just wonder if that elevated it for
our time cuz I feel like that's such a
big song like when I was growing up I
don't know no totally
and one last little fun packed for you
which I was super surprised to learn
instead of it being called can't hardly
wait they wanted to call it the party
which no no I guess it's really hard to
look back at something from the nineties
and be like uh it would have been that's
like something a bad title but I don't
like it exactly they ended up settling
on can't honey wheat because it was the
same name as a replacement song that
they were a big fan of so that's where
they landed um but I just had so much
fun watching this movie yeah a well a
backwards Easter egg I'm gonna give you
from josie and the pussycats
is when they're in there like
supplemental the messaging lab or
whatever it goes across and says can
hardly wait is underrated because it's
the same directors that's amazing oh my
gosh no but I just love that movie and
getting to revisit it with all of you
was so much fun yeah I mean diving back
into that vault I love I'm a sucker for
nostalgia hit me so uh I guess that that
leads into a question that I have yeah
for all of you is what are you watching
from your little vault and what should
we watch next cuz I'm always looking for
something that I have not seen watch and
we can talk about it together definitely
we want to hear your streaming
selections so definitely tweet with us
on Twitter you can find ash and I on
there and we even have an Ipsy hashtag
is hashtag watch with a team you know
assume it's down here in a grave
somewhere it's somewhere down here but
we really appreciate you guys streaming
with us chatting with us sharing your
thoughts I know it's a super crazy time
right now but Ashton I just really
appreciate it you use the hashtag so we
definitely see it and I I see what you
eat back here next week what do you say
definitely your couch my couch our crush
I guess it has to be super couches bye
guys thanks so much bye
[Music]